* Fröhlicher, afrikanischer Popsong:
"Pata Pata" von Miriam Makeba *
Manu und Jonny
vom Cabaretduo DivertiMento.
Seit zwei Wochen sind sie unterwegs:
quer durch Südafrika.
Das ist die letzte Etappe.
Sie ist voll mit neuen Abenteuern,
die sie an ihre Grenzen bringen.
Sich in etwas hineingeben,
etwas wagen -
das schadet eigentlich nie.
* Pfeifen, Jubel *
(Beide) Ja!
Ich staune immer wieder:
Ich kann überall hingehen,
irgendwie geht es schon.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Einen Platten, kurz vor dem
Nationalpark Baviaanskloof.
Die Parkwächter sind in der Nähe.
How's the road after the gate?
Die Strassen
werden also noch viel schlimmer.
* Aufgestellte, rhythmische Musik *
Baviaanskloof bedeutet:
Tal der Paviane.
Es ist ein riesiges Naturreservat,
völlig abgelegen.
200 km Schotterstrassen mit
Bergpässen und Flüssen ohne Brücken.
Ohne Allradantrieb
kommt man hier nicht vorwärts.
Jonny hat eine Scheissfreude
an diesem Schüttelbecher.
So ein Abenteuer in einem Reservat
wollte er unbedingt erleben.
Im Gegensatz zur Erdmännchen-Safari
letzte Woche,
bei der man v.a. Sitzleder benötigte.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen: Die Affen,
die hier über die Strasse rennen -
das ist für mich etwas anderes
als die Erdmännchen,
die ihre Schnauze
nach 1,5 Std aus dem Loch stecken.
Das hat mich jetzt schon ergriffen.
* Aufgestellte, rhythmische Musik *
Nach einigen Stunden
sind die beiden
am anderen Ende
von Baviaanskloof angekommen.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Jonny, kann man das jetzt
von der Bucket List streichen?
Ja - aber mit gutem Gewissen. Das
hat alle Erwartungen übertroffen.
Schau mal hier hinaus - mega!
* Sanfte Klänge *
Hat der Tonmeister jetzt gefurzt?
Ich glaube, ja.
- Oder?
Auch diese Nacht
verbringen die beiden
in ihren Zelten
auf dem Autodach.
Knapp die Hälfte der Strecke
haben Manu und Jonny hinter sich.
Die dritte und letzte Etappe bis
nach Johannesburg ist die längste.
Ich habe keine Lust!
- Bist du nervös?
Ich habe keine Lust
am Sonntagmorgen.
Als ich aufgewacht bin,
habe ich mal zurückgeschaut.
Es ist schon nach der Hälfte
eine unglaubliche Fülle
an Erlebnissen, Emotionen - primär
einfach eine überfüllte Festplatte.
So ist es bei mir.
- Ja.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie lange man alles aufnehmen kann.
Es sind jeden Tag
so viele neue Eindrücke - puh!
Darum würde ich schon gerne einfach
mal einen Tag irgendwo ...
Nichts Neues -
es ist auch fast alles schön.
Wenn man sich den ganzen Tag freut,
braucht das auch Kraft.
So blöd das klingt.
- Ja, das ist so.
* Fröhlicher Popsong: "I Just Can't
Wait to Be King" von John Oliver *
Auf die Erholung
müssen sie noch etwas warten.
Es ist weit bis nach Johannesburg.
Die Reise begann in Kapstadt.
Von der Baviaanskloof
geht's jetzt über Port Elizabeth
mit einigen Zwischenstopps
bis nach Johannesburg.
# I'm gonna be a mighty king,
so enemies beware.
# Well, I've never seen a king or
beast with quite so little hair.
In Hankey endet die Wildnis.
In dieser kleinen Stadt
leben fast keine Weisse.
Und Touristen
kommen auch nur selten vorbei.
Es ist Sonntagmorgen
und die Chancen stehen gut,
dass einer von Manus Wünschen
in Erfüllung geht.
Bei der Hinfahrt hörten wir
sie singen und jetzt ...
Manu, den Hut ausziehen.
* Mehrstimmiger Gesang, Klatschen *
Manu schrieb auf seine Bucket List,
dass er einen Gospel-Gottesdienst
miterleben möchte.
Ich bin wenig voyeuristisch
veranlagt.
Ich überrumple nicht gerne
andere Leute. - Ja.
Dann fühle ich mich unwohl, aber:
Vorhin, als sie loslegten und ich
merkte, dass sie sich wohlfühlen,
da hat es mich wirklich berührt,
weil ...
Es ist immer Musik und Gesang,
das gefällt mir sehr.
* Mehrstimmiger Gesang, Klatschen *
Das war für mich
ein wunderschönes Bild,
kurz in dieses echte Leben
hineinzuschauen.
Ich hätte gern mehr gesehen.
Es ist ein wenig wie zu Hause.
Wer am Sonntag nicht in die Kirche
geht, schaut Fussball.
Oh!
- Das habe ich verpasst.
Ah, they are the hosts?
(Alle) Yes! Yes!
Das eigene Team kassiert ein Tor.
Aber die Fans lassen sich
die Stimmung nicht verderben.
Jetzt gibt's Penalty,
schau mal.
Raus!
(Beide) Ja!
* Euphorische Musik, Jubel *
* Aufgestellte Musik *
Die Reise geht weiter
Richtung Port Elizabeth.
Und von dort nach Chintsa.
Das liegt an der Wild Coast,
eine Gegend mit grünen Klippen
und weissen Stränden.
* Aufgestellte, rhythmische Musik *
We have to go to ... Jeans.
Wie heisst es?
(Er ahmt ihn nach) Chintsa.
- Sorry, yes, now it's open.
* Fröhliche Musik *
And me, could I also have
a little bit?
Yes, sorry - the driver
is very important. - Thank you.
(Beide) No, congratulation!
That's awesome!
Bye!
- (Beide) Bye-bye!
In der Gegend von Chintsa leben die
Xhosa, ein südafrikanisches Urvolk.
Manu und Jonny möchten mehr über
die Traditionen des Stamms erfahren.
Die Xhosa haben
eine ganz besondere Sprache.
* Er macht schmatzende Geräusche. *
* Sie machen schnalzende Geräusche. *
* Mehrstimmiger Gesang,
Stampfen, Klatschen *
In diesem Dorf lebt eine Frau,
die man weitherum kennt.
Zinzi Tofu. Mit ihrer Tanzgruppe
zeigt sie den Besuchern,
wie die Xhosa leben
und worauf sie stolz sind.
* Jonny lacht. *
Okay!
Oh my god!
Einen Moment zuschauen - gerne.
Aber lernen ...
Es sind drei verschiedene Dinge ...
- Ja!
Am Anfang muss man sich immer
einen grossen Tritt geben,
es auszuprobieren,
sich blosszustellen.
Jetzt beginnt es aber,
Spass zu machen.
Und sie nehmen es easy.
They take it easy.
Das Lied gehört
zu einem sog. Intonjane.
Ein Ritual,
das die Xhosa zelebrieren,
wenn aus einem Mädchen
eine Frau wird.
* Kraftvoller, schnalzender Gesang *
* Kraftvoller, mehrstimmiger Gesang *
Der Kreis mit einem Holzrad rundherum
heisst Kraal.
Hierhin
dürfen nur die Männer des Dorfs -
und die heimliche Chefin, Zinzi.
Es war wirklich sehr schön.
Beim Tanzen waren wir alleine
mit den Damen und Mädchen.
Und jetzt, wo es etwas zu trinken
gibt, kamen die Männer auch.
Er schaut schon ganz gierig.
Man trinkt hier Umqombothi,
ein Maisbier,
das nicht viel
mit unserem Bier zu tun hat.
Er hat es schon runtergeschüttet.
* Sie sprechen
einen schnalzenden Satz nach. *
Ah, mit dem Schnalz? Klick?
- Amagu, ja.
Oh, sie verzieht das Gesicht.
Willst du auch? Nein?
Ja, das ist gut für die Seele.
Manu und Jonny
dürfen zum Abendessen bleiben.
Es gibt Umngqusho - eine Art Polenta
mit Bohnen, dazu Poulet.
Was sie im Dorf der Xhosa
erlebt haben, gibt ihnen zu denken.
Es ist Horror zuzuschauen,
wie die Frauen tanzen müssen,
damit ihre Männer saufen können.
(Beide) Das ist krass.
- Es wird wohl einfach toleriert.
Der Mann scheint hier hierarchisch
völlig oberhalb der Frau zu sein.
Ihnen zuzuschauen, wie sie tanzen,
wie sie sich bewegen können,
der Gesang - da geht mir
das Herz auf, das ist so schön.
Ja, wirklich.
Kinderstimmen, zusammen
mit den Stimmen der Alten.
* Kinderstimmen, Gesang *
Manu?
- Ja?
Wie war das Gesamterlebnis?
Ich bin völlig happy -
ich habe keine Zeit zum Reden!
* Mehrstimmiger Gesang, Klatschen *
* Lachen *
Gesang, Tanz, von einem Stamm,
quasi einem Urvolk -
das haben wir erlebt.
Jonny und Manu wissen nie,
was sie auf dieser Reise
als Nächstes erwartet.
Nur, dass sie heute in der Nähe von
Port St. Johns am Meer übernachten.
Unterwegs fahren sie am Geburtsort
von Nelson Mandela vorbei.
Der Mann, der ein Leben lang für
Freiheit und Gerechtigkeit kämpfte.
Es sieht aus, als ob Petrus
die Gebete der Gläubigen in Hankey
gehört hat: Es beginnt zu regnen.
Jetzt waren wir so lange
verwöhnt vom Wetter -
aber ich mag es gerne garstig.
Aufgepasst - aber ich
trage die weissen Schuhe,
das nervt mich ein wenig
mit diesem Pflotsch hier.
Schau mal, da unten ist das Meer!
(Mit verstellter Stimme) Das Meer,
schau mal, schau mal, das Meer!
Die beiden sind am Ziel. Das ist der
Indische Ozean bei Port St. Johns.
In dieser Gegend
leben besonders viele Aussteiger,
es gibt die eine
oder andere Hippie-Unterkunft.
Hier übernachten
v.a. Rucksacktouristen,
die es möglichst einfach
haben wollen.
Heute auch Manu und Jonny.
Toll. Toll.
Hey! Weg!
Gut, haben wir
die Wanderschuhe an.
Ich wusste doch nicht, dass wir
in diesem Morast ankommen.
Wo sind wir hier gelandet?
Das Licht brennt noch.
Ja, schmuck sieht das hier aus.
Hi.
- Bonjour.
Bonjour, ca va bien, merci, et vous?
Sorry, I am just having
a little sleep.
(Beide) No problem.
Nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you, I'm Jonny.
Okay cool!
* Fröhlicher Rocksong: "The Lion
Sleeps Tonight" von Scallwags *
Hello.
- Hi.
I'm Tony, hi.
- Nice to meet you.
Ja, es ist einfach, ein wenig
schmuddelig - das kann man sagen.
Nach 6 Std. Reise,
wenn ich ankomme ...
Dann regnet es so
und alles ist ein wenig run down.
Eine Nacht hier zu bleiben,
ist völlig in Ordnung.
Ja, ja. Ich ziehe jetzt mal
die anderen Schuhe an.
Moon Boots!
Ein kleines Bierchen
von unserem Gastgeber.
Ah, ein kleines.
* Fröhlicher Rocksong: "The Lion
Sleeps Tonight" von Scallwags *
Ich konnte meine Zähne nicht putzen,
ich muss Kaugummi kauen.
Sie haben nicht mal ein Waschbecken.
Ich kann die Linsen
nicht rausnehmen,
weil ich die Hände
nicht waschen kann.
Ich bin froh, wenn wir morgen
wieder ins Auto steigen
und weiterfahren können.
Nein, ich bin doch nicht genervt,
was denkst du denn?
Bei purer Begeisterung
spürt man das nicht.
Das ist klar ausserhalb
meiner Komfortzone.
Warum?
Schmuddelig, dreckig,
es hat tote Insekten,
man musste den Staub
erst wegwischen.
Es ist eklig. Einfach nur eklig.
Igitt! Ich liege sogar
auf dem ekligen Kissen,
auf dem sicher schon 14 Teenager ...
Nein!
Ich habe noch
ein Tuch hingelegt,
damit ich friedlich sabbern kann,
ohne dass ...
Ab jetzt, geht nach Hause,
mach das Licht aus, das blendet!
Was die beiden nicht wissen:
Schon in der nächsten Nacht
wären sie froh um dieses Zimmer.
* Sanfte Flötenklänge *
Es war eine kurze Nacht.
Aber wenn die Sonne scheint, sieht
das Leben wieder ganz anders aus.
Das ist echt schön.
Ambi: Wild Coast.
* Rhythmische Musik *
Dort hat es zwei!
- Ja, oder? Drei, dort, ja!
Und dort noch einmal zwei.
- Hammer!
Der ist geil.
- Schau mal, wow!
(Beide) Wow!
Da wimmelt es, schau mal.
Sie sind so weit vorne.
Schau mal, schau mal!
- Wow das sind ja ... wow, shit!
Jetzt musst du schauen,
bam, bam, bam.
Der Tag hat sehr schön begonnen mit
dieser Delfinschule in den Wellen.
Das ist ein schöner Start
in den Tag.
Nein, ich habe Tränen in den Augen -
aber eher,
weil meine Linsen verklebt sind.
Es ist alles gut - ich schimpfe
einfach gerne, das ist tipptopp,
das gehört bereits
zu der Verarbeitung.
Ich staune immer wieder:
Ich kann überall hingehen,
irgendwie geht es schon.
Ich hatte eine beschissene,
aber völlig harmlose Nacht.
Es ist alles in Ordnung.
* Fröhlicher, afrikanischer Popsong:
"Pata Pata" von Miriam Makeba *
Der Wild Coast entlang
geht es weiter Richtung Nordosten.
Durch viele kleine Dörfchen
Richtung Durban.
In dieser Millionenstadt
am Indischen Ozean
fanden die Spiele
der Fussball-WM 2010 statt.
Hier hat die Schweiz Spanien
mit 1:0 geschlagen.
Jetzt sehen wir bald das Stadion.
Wow, schön, nicht wahr?
* Fröhlicher, afrikanischer Popsong:
"Pata Pata" von Miriam Makeba *
Manu und Jonny fahren
durch die Provinz KwaZulu-Natal.
Es ist die Heimat der Zulu,
dem stolzen Kriegervolk.
Oh, das sieht aber schön aus.
Wo sind wir hier gelandet?
In der Nähe der Stadt Eshowe.
Das ist der Ausgangspunkt
für ein Abenteuer,
das die beiden
noch sehr beschäftigen wird.
Ja - arbeiten wir jetzt
hier im Service?
Hello.
- Hello.
Good evening, nice to meet you.
- Good to meet you.
Manu.
- Manu? - Yes.
Welcome.
- Thank you.
Spannend -
ich weiss nichts über sie.
Das wird funny.
Und jetzt muss ich aufs WC.
(Telefon) Jonny, links oder rechts?
- Right, then left.
Right, then left.
Left ...
- Ah, sorry, jetzt left?
(Telefon) Now left?
- Ja.
And then right.
- Jetzt gleich rechts abbiegen.
(Telefon) Fahrt voraus.
- Das wäre besser.
Die Zulu sind mit über 11 Mio. Men-
schen das grösste Volk in Südafrika.
Die meisten leben in kleinen Dörfern,
über das Land verstreut.
Gugu bringt die Gäste aus der Schweiz
zur Familie von Walter Cele,
dem Old Man.
So sagt man dem Familienoberhaupt
bei den Zulus.
So. Jetzt sind wir hier
bei einer Zulu-Family.
Hello.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
Londega.
- Londega.
Das ist spannend.
Hello, nice to meet you, Walter.
* Lachen, Ausrufe *
Er hat mir an den Sack gegriffen.
Man liest überall, wie
gastfreundlich sie in Afrika sind -
das ist wirklich warmherzig!
Aber das ist erst der Anfang.
Gugu bringt Manu und Jonny
zu einer Siedlung in der Nähe.
Hier soll eine
der geheimnisvollen Sangoma leben.
Eine Frau, die die Zukunft voraussagt
und Menschen heilen kann.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Man sagt, dass Sangoma den Geist
ihrer Vorfahren in sich tragen
und darum so viel wissen.
Der Besuch bei einer Sangoma
ist etwas Alltägliches.
Acht von zehn Südafrikanern lassen
sich mehrmals pro Jahr so behandeln.
Was ich hier gerade erleben durfte -
es war spannend -,
halte ich für Unsinn.
Keine Ahnung,
ob ich hier jemandem zu nahe trete.
Ja, in meinen Augen ist das Unsinn -
in meinen Ohren auch.
Sie war auch nicht informiert,
dass wir kommen,
sie war vielleicht
auch schlecht vorbereitet.
Aber inhaltlich
kann ich es nicht bestätigen.
Ein gutes Medium bräuchte doch
eigentlich keine Vorbereitung.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ambi: Zulu-Land.
Wir gehen zurück zu Walter,
unserem Haudegen. - Absolut.
Unterdessen ist der wohl
schon bei mir im Schlafsack.
Das wird also toll!
Ich bin gespannt,
wie und wo wir nächtigen werden.
* Wilde Trommelklänge *
Beautiful!
Marihuana?
- Marihuana?
Against stress, come and see.
- Okay.
Es ist lustig -
ich musste mich schon gestern
bei Dylan ein wenig überwinden.
Und das hier, das kann man
nicht damit vergleichen.
Das ist ...
Einer von uns
bleibt die ganze Nacht wach,
damit nicht der Chef reinkommt
und zuschlägt.
Ich habe ein bisschen Angst.
* Wilde Trommelklänge,
Lachen, Ausrufe *
Das habe ich wirklich
noch nie erlebt.
Es ist ein Abend,
der Spuren hinterlässt.
Der Abend gestern
blieb mir noch lange im Kopf.
Wir haben ja dann versucht, ausführ-
licher mit dem Gastgeber zu reden.
Und alle sind ziemlich erschrocken.
Wie eng und wie klein
seine Welt ist.
Das hat mich sehr beschäftigt.
Wenn man bei den Zulu ist - da hätte
ich gerne etwas von ihrem Stolz,
etwas von ihrer Würde,
von ihrer Philosophie erfahren.
Und wir haben eigentlich
nur gelernt,
sich mit Alkohol zuzuschütten,
die Frauen so zu benutzen,
wie sie gerade da sind.
Das ist ein wenig enttäuschend.
Das Gute ist: Wenn man
in einem See am Ertrinken ist,
und man ganz am Grund ankommt,
dann kann man sich wieder abstossen.
Und da sind wir jetzt, wir stossen
uns ab, jetzt geht es aufwärts.
Die beiden fahren zurück zu Gugu.
Aber so schnell
geht es doch nicht aufwärts.
Jonny hatte gestern Abend
eine Diskussion mit Walter,
in der es um Homosexualität ging.
Die Meinung des Old Man
gibt Manu und Jonny zu denken.
Das ist um ein Haar eskaliert.
Und das stimmt einen sehr,
sehr nachdenklich.
Der hat sieben Frauen,
17 Mädchen und fünf Jungs.
Die Frauen
haben gar nichts zu sagen.
Sie sind wirklich Paschas,
die sich bedienen lassen.
Nichts! Sie können saufen,
sie sind faule Hunde.
Schwule muss man töten.
Nein, abartige Ansichten,
das ist echt, das ist ...
Ich wurde sehr oft geschlagen
von ihm, den ganzen Abend,
ich habe alles
mit viel Humor genommen.
Solange ich konnte,
ging ich mit viel Empathie
und dem nötigen Respekt mit ihm um.
Aber irgendwann war es genug,
das ging nicht mehr.
Wenn es darum geht,
dass man gleich töten muss,
auch wenn man nur
ein wenig anders lebt.
Da mussten wir aufpassen,
dass ich mich beherrschen konnte.
Ja, da hat nicht viel gefehlt.
Es ist auch eine Wut aufgekommen.
Let's fight on.
- It's so impressive.
* Kraftvoller Popsong:
"Circle of Life" von Carmen Twillie *
Der Besuch bei den Zulu
ist ein Kapitel,
das die beiden nicht so leicht
abschliessen können.
Aber auch das gehört zu Südafrika.
Genau wie das letzte Abenteuer,
das vor ihnen liegt.
* Kraftvoller Popsong:
"Circle of Life" von Carmen Twillie *
Das ist das Tor
zum Hluhluwe-iMfolozi-Park.
Juhu!
Endlich kann Manu die Safari machen,
die seit dem Beginn
auf seiner Bucket List steht.
# From the day we arrive
on the planet.
# And blinking, step into the sun.
Das ist schön, wow!
# There's more to be seen
than can ever be seen,
# more to do than can ever be done.
# It's the circle of life.
# And it moves us all.
# On the path unwinding.
# In the circle, the circle of life.
Manu und Jonny haben mitten
im Nationalpark übernachtet.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Er kommt da,
er hat uns voll im Visier.
Ein Elefant kam auf unser Haus zu,
ein einsamer Bulle.
Wir wollten ihn filmen,
aber er ging auf uns los.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Wow, wir hatten alle
ein wenig Angst.
Es ist krass,
das ist ein Riesenmöbel.
Ich hätte filmen sollen,
aber ich hatte Angst.
Ambi, iMfolozi Game Reserve.
Nach der Begegnung mit dem Elefanten
geht's zu Fuss weiter.
Manu möchte noch mehr Tiere sehen.
Das Tracking, Spurenlesen -
das finde ich sehr interessant.
Jonny wollte eigentlich
keine Safari machen.
Schau mal, so läuft es doch.
Ich merke doch, dass das Manu
sehr viel bedeutet, ihn fasziniert.
Und ich möchte diese Faszination
nachvollziehen können.
Dann bin ich auch so offen,
dass ich mitkomme
und nicht allzu fest
am Stänkern bin - bis jetzt.
Letztendlich ist es doch
überall so im Leben.
Sich in etwas hineingeben,
etwas wagen,
das schadet eigentlich nie,
finde ich.
Der Stecken-Tourist da hinten.
Er ist voll dabei.
Für den Gegenschnitt,
dachte ich.
Wäre es manchmal einfacher,
wenn ihr euch ähnlicher wärt?
Nein, bestimmt nicht.
Die Andersartigkeit des Gegenübers -
das ist in jeder Beziehung
eine Herausforderung.
Und jene Dinge,
die ich an Manu am meisten liebe,
nerven mich auch am meisten.
Und da lernen wir gegenseitig
voneinander.
Ich staune immer wieder,
wie weitherzig Manu ist.
Gegenüber Situationen,
aber v.a. gegenüber Menschen.
Es gab in den letzten 20 Jahren
auch Momente,
in denen ich die Formulierung seiner
Emotionen zu früh, zu schnell fand.
Aber das ist eines der vielen Dinge,
die ich in den letzten 20 Jahren
von Jonny gelernt habe.
Direktheit.
Ja, ich trage mein Herz
einfach auf der Zunge.
Das war schon immer so,
das bleibt auch so.
Und so wird das Ende dieser Reise
auch zum Fazit einer Freundschaft,
die die beiden seit 20 Jahren
durch dick und dünn trägt.
Wir haben schon auch Dinge erlebt,
in einem Hoch,
und das tat auch gut, zusammen wie-
der einmal etwas Neues zu erleben.
Zu Hause, in unserem Touralltag,
erleben wir auch Schönes.
Sehr viel sogar, aber daran gewöhnt
man sich trotzdem ein wenig.
Hier kamen neue Dinge auf uns zu
und es ist schön,
das mit einem Buddy zu teilen.
Aber hier unterwegs, wir zu zweit,
ich muss sagen:
Der Applaus im Saal ist das eine.
Aber etwas vom Schönsten
ist für mich immer noch,
wenn ich Jonny zum Lachen
bringen kann - nach 20 Jahren.
Das bleibt etwas sehr Besonderes.
Das gab es oft, sehr oft.
- Gleichfalls.
Ich musste sehr oft lachen, klar.
Ich arbeite mit Manu zusammen,
weil ich ihn lustig finde.
Oh, ein Insekt!
Das ist eine Bewegungssensorkamera.
Sobald in diesem Bereich
eine Bewegung erkannt wird,
wird sie ausgelöst
und macht einen 15-sekündigen Film.
Ich musste die Wildkamera mitnehmen,
wenn ich schon mal in Afrika bin.
Wir werden sehen, ob heute Nacht,
während wir schlafen,
Tiere in unserem Camp
herumschleichen.
* Zwitschern, Zirpen *
* Zirpen, Plätschern *
* Aufgestellte, rhythmische Klänge *
Es war die letzte Nacht in Südafrika.
Und der letzte Punkt, der
auf der Bucket List gestrichen wird.
Safari, Wildlife.
* Sanfter Popsong:
"Africa" von Toto *
# It's gonna take a lot
to drag me away from you.
# There's nothing that a hundred men
or more could ever do.
# I bless the rains down in Africa.
Johannesburg.
Manu und Jonny sind am Ziel.
* Sanfter, zweistimmiger Gesang *
# Merci beaucoup, it was so nice.
# Ci vediamo, bis zur nöchste Reis.
# Es het gfägt, was a joy ...
# Grazie a voi.
# Mier gönd jetzt hei,
goodbye, goodbye.
# Vai, va-va-va-va-va-vai.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Laura Thomann - 2019